[Music]
thank you
speaking of head trauma I'm glad
Anderson Silva only experienced a little
yeah
I was so yeah tell me your thoughts on
the whole thing I was elated with that
result some people thought I was like oh
he took an L to Jake Paul I couldn't
care about that yeah I it Jake could
have been anyone I just don't want to
see
um my dad take anymore
Anderson yeah yeah okay okay major was
he the one that broke his like yes okay
yes yes yeah he's like a legend right I
know I know I know he is I'm just you
know you know it's for you guys
but he is a legend though right yeah
okay yeah yeah see yeah he's a legend
you guys okay Cody I know that I just
was making sure that everyone else okay
so my thoughts on the fight people
so when I was you know
uh when we talked about the Jake fight
before and I promise I won't make this
like the fight hour for too long
so I was critical of Jake in the
beginning and I was like no one's really
tested him this was exactly the fight he
needed to have to demonstrate
that he
um has like a certain certain qualities
right like what's your instincts when
someone puts the fire on you you know
like uh which he's demonstrated he
demonstrated a lot in the way of
improvement and it's it's undeniable
that part he got the fire put on him and
he shot back he had good instincts you
know when he was getting traded on he he
didn't like cover up and then just shut
down he was still like trying to throw
in the pocket
whatever horse steroids Anderson was on
I need that okay he ate some bombs yeah
yeah like at 50 years old you ate that
[ __ ] yeah and kept it
you only got knocked down once yeah I
need it yeah whatever you're on dude I
want that that's the main thing I was
really thinking
um I thought
it was a great fight in the way that you
got to see some classic Anderson Silva
making Jake Miss I thought that was
crazy yeah that was pretty cool when he
started doing that [ __ ] we started
getting cocky I'm like please not like
this yeah it's like you can do you could
I know you did that when you were 28 you
are 47. please stop that is that how old
he is 47 yeah dude he's 47. damn that's
psycho to get in there at 47 years old
and fight a 23 year old how much you get
paid
probably a good ass amount good ass yeah
you know they made sure they got those
bets in
who was favored uh Jake okay by a lot
was he yeah
Silva was a decent under it was it was
entertaining I will say no it was a jake
brought out he offered some of the best
Anderson entertainment in a minute yeah
and it's crazy at 47 years old how his
hands still work that good yeah all his
like subtle psychological [ __ ] like
every time they pushed out the clinch
the way he would just push him on the
neck and he was like Jake would like tie
up and he would earlier in the rounds he
was like Jake let go let go and he's
like smacking him on the lower back and
just spanking him let go let go of daddy
yeah you know just it was like
interesting to see how all those gears
were still turning and how even when
they'd clinch Anderson didn't shy away
from like the uppercuts and you know
just just staying busy that that part
was crazy to see for an old man a jake
definitely like took a lot of punishment
and showed like he he has it what I'm
curious now is like okay his X Factor
is his knockout power
he ran into someone who might have been
on horse steroids but it didn't shut him
off
so it makes me wonder how would Jake
perform against a guy that's closer to
his prime meaning like another fighter
who's not older and and honestly I don't
really agree with the criticism of like
oh Jake only fights old men he fights
cans that's literally every fighter yeah
every Fighter's early record they're not
going out there and fighting like real
you know great fighters in the way that
like they want wins yeah you know their
coaches are trying to build their
confidence in this and that
so I don't really think that's like a a
strong critique you can make of him but
I think okay now he's had like four or
five fights or whatever
um six six now is it six yeah my man is
6-0 no okay I know my man's record yeah
yeah of course yeah
your boy yeah my boy
I think it's 6-0 yeah can you check I'm
pretty sure it is I was on his Instagram
after it it's it's whatever I mean five
and no six and no he's undefeated I'm
just curious to see now how he would do
against the fighter closer to their
Prime I think you know okay Anderson's
old he's obviously great I don't want to
say this and take anything away from him
but
Anderson was able to make him Miss and
Anderson was able to take some of his
punishment that he dishes back so I'm
curious to see how Jake performs against
a guy who can take the punishment that
he issues and then dish but can dish it
back yeah you know yeah because uh he
definitely you know he he showed a lot
of class and uh
it like I don't it's no skin off my back
to admit that I'm just curious to see
now I don't think anyone can be like oh
he needs to fight a real boxer he fought
a real ass boxer yeah that fight yeah
okay he was in there but I think to say
he needs to fight a seasoned boxer or a
more Prime boxer I think that's that's a
fair thing to
to bring about now
and I think that's really the only
direction for him to go you know yeah
and and his Camp has done it right like
scaling up the skill set you know Ben
asked her and that was that was nothing
yeah Tyron was a great matchup for him
you know but this is what boxing is it's
like finding good matchups and finding
ways to win do you think he will
actually fight a like uh you know
someone more primed yeah but it's still
probably gonna be a fight that's in his
favor it was like a great measured test
for their Camp to see like how he
responds to punishment he looked nervous
as [ __ ] going into that fight naturally
you know I don't say that to be critical
I think anyone would be
but uh yeah I was I was very surprised
that his right hand didn't put Anderson
away yeah and I was just glad to see
that yeah he lives in Puerto Rico yeah
the fact that he fights out of Puerto
Rico is crazy yeah him and his brother
it's crazy because you like don't pay
taxes there I guess yeah you don't it's
a it's a funny thing right what because
like now Jake is definitely doing things
with his platform to be like positive
right like fight or pay yeah which is
undeniably positive you can't be mad at
that yeah he's he's taking head on
something that
the UFC and other people dance around
you know that they but it's kind of like
it's like a marketing thing right right
so it's like how genuine is it yeah is
this what he does now like he's a pro
like he promotes fights yeah he's trying
to create I mean he has created a fight
promotion that uh was his fight promo
yeah between him and Anderson yeah yeah
you know you hate to see it the school
bullies continues to be more successful
we do not even need the [ __ ] we don't
even need to look at that put that off
I'd rather see the Walkman lyrics again
actually no dude you actually
you handed him one of his only fight
elves
[Laughter]
he tried to go in there and get busy
with you and everyone was like you're a
[ __ ] dork
he's not undefeated yeah that's that's a
good point although if he threw any sort
of punch he would have he would have
taken that he would have shut you out
yeah he would shut you down in a second
oh yeah you know but so violence is the
answer sometimes sometimes it's the
answer I love how he gets up there and
he's like I just wanted to see anyone
seeing this you can do it so you can
beat the [ __ ] out of anybody
you could start get you could get
popular on the internet like scam kids
out of money
you know you don't have like [ __ ] the
Disney Channel yeah you can beat up an
old dude if you want
I mean you can't you know you can you
can join your local gym get in it with
you know get an amateur bout and beat up
an old man